todo mundo tem uma idéia
todo mundo tem uma idéia todo mundo
pensa alguma coisa em algum momento
desde a sua infância a refletir sobre o
mundo sobre a vida aquela teoria que
você tem que seu amigo que você conversa
na mesa de bar em que você discutir
sobre como aquilo pra você faz sentidos
ea ideia que eu tive um tempo atrás e já
me perguntei onde isso começou
e continuo me perguntando é a gente tem
acesso hoje uma série de informações
nós estamos mais conectados do que nunca
mas independente disso a gente passa
todos os dias por vários ambientes por
várias pessoas
a gente vê várias coisas a gente olha
pra alguém ver a roupa que essa pessoa
está usando mais gente ignora essa
informação
então alguém que passou por mim é no
metrô quando tava vindo pra cá eu não
prestei atenção eu não sei quem é eu não
lembro a informação foi absorvida pelos
meus sentidos analisada pelo meu cérebro
e descartada
meu cérebro jogou assim foi jogou essa
informação inútil
só que a pergunta que eu tenho é e se
essa informação for inútil e se essa
pessoa que passou por mim que o meu
cérebro ignorou for acusada de um crime
acontecer alguma coisa com ela
se essa pessoa ou reencontrar ela daqui
cinco anos ela se tornará melhor amiga
será que essa informação realmente foi
relevante
e aí a gente pudesse captar cada vez
mais informações
se a gente pudesse pegar as informações
que nosso cérebro julga inúteis e fazer
alguma coisa com elas
se a gente pudesse tirar proveito dela
isso levou cada vez mais a prestar
atenção a querer ver as coisas que
passam desapercebidos e procurar elas um
significado tudo gera informação tudo já
um significado e se eu pudesse ter
acesso a mais informações em seu poder e
se eu pudesse entender mais com as
coisas funcionam e se eu pudesse prestar
atenção não só na roupa que as pessoas
estão usando não que seja um fato
relevante mas em como as pessoas agem em
como as coisas se comportam se eu fizer
isso qualquer efeito que isso vai ter
e começar a partir disso entender melhor
o mundo entender melhor as pessoas
entender melhor tudo que me cercam
será que conseguiria lidar com a minha
realidade de uma forma diferente
vou contar para vocês algumas situações
em que se prestar atenção pra mim fez
toda a diferença é no começo de 2015 foi
parar na terra naquela terra ali eu
passei 50 dias na índia como voluntário
no orfanato trabalhava com educação de
órfãos junto com pessoas de mais de 10
países diferentes
e aí depois de várias horas de vôo
várias crianças chorando no avião uma
comida indiana que eu nunca tinha
experimentado que eu chorei a primeira
vez que o comitê também alimenta eu
cheguei ali numa cidade que fica bem no
centro da índia chamada a idéia ba e
chegando lá é é sim
as vacas estão nas ruas é uma
experiência cultural muito interessante
ea cada coisa cada informação pequena
que eu olhava aquilo me chocava e aquilo
me fazia questionar tudo que eu
acreditava os meus valores a minha
cultura porque no brasil como arroz com
feijão
eu imagino que ninguém tenha se
perguntado isso mas são perguntas
pequenas que a gente começa a fazer
quando a gente começa a olhar as coisas
e um é é um ângulo diferente
isso é uma típica rua indiana
então não tem calçada tem vários carros
é várias pessoas como as roupas muito
diferente da nossa e muitos barulhos
muitas coisas eu costumo falar que a
índia é um país muito aí já me mudou
muito mas ao mesmo tempo é um país com
muito dinheiro muita desigualdade
muita gente muita comida mas ao mesmo
tempo muita fome é eu vi lá um cenário
social muito forte muito parecido mas ao
mesmo tempo muito diferente com o nosso
e foi lá que eu digo que eu virei outra
pessoa tão o henrique que subiu no avião
que já dois janeiro não foi o mesmo que
retornou para o brasil devem ser de
fevereiro a ser falado que eu trabalhava
então as crianças tinham
de 4 a 10 anos eu trabalhava com pessoas
da botsuana da malásia da colômbia e do
brasil
eu tinha todos os dias um ambiente que
me desafiava a todo momento e durante
esses 50 dias tiveram dois momentos em
que você sente um personagem me senti um
personagem de um filme sabe quando pára
e parece que você vai subindo a câmera
assim é parece que deus te olhando de
cima e ainda da sua cara tipo a você
para oe para este mundo inteiro para
você tem uma jornada na sua cabeça por
alguns segundos em que parece que toda
sua vida muda um desses momentos foi
isso
então um dia eu estava com os outros
voluntários que trabalhavam comigo neste
campeonato ea gente compra cartolina
comprar tinta o nosso objetivo era
trazer uma tentativa de uma perspectiva
de futuro dessas crianças então crianças
carentes com baixo acesso à educação
como que a gente poderia fazer algo por
elas
a ideia era que a gente eles pintassem é
desenhar sem alguma forma representa
assim que eles queriam para o futuro e
eu venho de uma realidade de classe
média onde tive a oportunidade eo
privilégio de estudar numa escola
particular por toda a minha vida é
estudar numa universidade particular e a
resposta deles me deu um grande tapa
porque é algo que sempre tive contato
sempre esteve do meu lado mas eu nunca
olhei anos
então quando os voluntários nós vamos
pedimos que eles apresentassem é é as
meninas elas trouxeram alguns desenhos
a bela explica ainda então é o que eu
queria para o meu futuro é minha casa
minha família comida coisas muito o que
às vezes a gente não pára para reparar o
quanto é importante a gente entra não
automático na nossa rotina com o
trabalho com o estudo com as
expectativas que nós temos sobre nossas
expectativas que os outros têm sobre nós
ea gente não enxerga pra essas coisas
e foi nesse momento em que parece
mundo para o e deus melhor de cima sem
falar você se pergunte questione mais
repense no que você acredita porque são
coisas que eu tive o privilégio de ter
durante a minha vida só que talvez nunca
tinha dado um determinado valor e aí
seguindo é esse momento já foi um
momento muito forte pra mim eu já tava
muito questionador sempre foi uma pessoa
que se perguntou muito sobre as coisas
então já me questionava por que a vaca
estava na rua porque que é o trânsito
era daquele jeito porque tudo era tão
intenso e aí os dias seguirão a gente
continuar freqüentando a nato e vários
questionamentos começaram a surgir pra
mim então teve um momento em que eu
fiquei sozinho com 40 crianças e eu
falei low e agora que eu vou fazer é
conversando passar mais alguns dias e
ainda aquele fato que estava trabalhando
acontecer um problema
o pessoal da organização que estava
recebendo lá que era uma organização que
intermediava a organização a a ong
riovoluntário falar não vamos mudar
vamos começar e aí eu fui trabalhar um
segundo fato é nesse segundo a nato meu
primeiro dia já foi um choque eu não
tive muito tempo muito tempo pa para
pensar falar e aí como estão as coisas
então era um domingo à tarde eu cheguei
nesse segundo renata trabalhava só com
brasileiros e já que eu cheguei no
domingo 6 horas da tarde às sete horas
da noite tal e aí escurecendo foi tentar
acender a luz nós em dia é neste momento
a segui-la nuno diretor do orfanato
não tem porque não senti a e ele me
respondeu meio de cabeça baixa e com
vergonha um pouco constrangido
então é que cortaram a luz ontem que a
gente não tinha dinheiro pra pagar
segundo a famato ele brigava mais ou
menos 35 crianças também facilitar um
pouco mais avançada entre 7 e 15 anos
e aí eu me reuni junto com os outros
brasileiros nós éramos em 6 naquele
momento e agente perguntou ah tá quanto
que é a conta
ele falou 700 super som
hoje o real está mais valorizado mas na
época 700 rúbia será algo em torno de
r$30 então 35 crianças estavam sem luz
por um mês por causa de 35 reais e o
primeiro questionamento que eu faço pra
vocês é o quanto vocês vão gastar no
almoço de vocês hoje o quanto vocês
gravaram ontem em um jantar em no dia a
dia de vocês enquanto que o custo de
vida de cada um e foi um momento em que
a gente falou tá e aí a gente tem um
quadro a gente tem uma situação a gente
pode trabalhar para mudar isso a gente
pode vim aqui fazer o básico que a gente
se propôs a fazer era dar um apoio
inglês dá um apoio na educação dessas
crianças tentar trazer o mesmo trabalho
que eu já realizava em orfanatos aqui
com uma equipe diferente e a gente
chegou
a gente juntou ele falou tá vamos usar o
que a gente tem nesse momento o facebook
né tá na mão aí todo mundo resolveu
criar um evento no facebook a gente fez
um vídeo a gente colocou 10 mil pessoas
no evento tivemos três mil confirmados
em uma semana a gente tinha arrecadado
entre 2.500 e 3.000 reais em uma série
de pessoas aqui no brasil que se
propuseram a ajudar
mandaram dinheiro pra gente a gente vê
todo dia no banco acaba de pouco em
pouco porque não podia sacar tudo de uma
vez porque do nada aquelas 700 super que
faltavam em que a gente na hora teve a
oportunidade de dar o dinheiro é produto
da ong ea luz religada no dia seguinte
aquelas 700 mil para se tornarem 60 mil
e conforme a gente entregando esse
dinheiro para o dono daquilo que a nato
é ficava mais intenso a gratidão dele
mas a gratidão dele não é a questão uma
gratidão nossa era a questão então muita
gente pensava para um lugar vou ajudar
os outros
vou falar que estou fazendo um trabalho
voluntário vou ser visto como uma pessoa
legal e quando eu fui eu fui no meu ego
de achar que eu estava lá indo para lá
para ensinar
eu estava indo pra lá pra fazer algo por
aquelas pessoas mas elas me fizeram me
ensinaram muito mais
essa foto foi no último dia no orfanato
em que a gente fez essa doação
é é te ver aquelas crianças agradecendo
a gente no último dia eu chorava muito
mais do que ela tem que me pedir eu
chegar aqui até o momento que começamos
a tirar assim não consegue parar e ela
me abraçava falava não chora não chora
eu estava mais e foi um momento em que
eu me senti como se nada em volta
pudesse dar errado
não existe nenhum problema e estava tudo
certo porque era tão um especial era tão
forte pra mim aquela sensação que talvez
tenha sido o momento de maior gratidão
que a sentir por aquelas crianças e por
aquelas pessoas e eu pensei tá eu voltar
para o brasil daqui uma semana e aí será
que acaba essa história acaba aqui que
eu vou fazer com isso que eu aprendi é
seria um grande erro meu não
compartilhar isso com ninguém não tentar
fazer com que são explicados
essa organização que me levou até a
índia já trabalhava nela eu falei tá
como eu posso fazer com que mais pessoas
tenham a experiência que eu tive eu
trabalhava é eu entrei nessa em setembro
de 2014 2014
essa organização é me levou pra inter no
começo de 2015
eu voltei comecei a assumir cargos mais
altos até o ponto que eu falei tá se és
eu sinto a responsabilidade se
multiplicar essas histórias de
multiplicar experiências e ensinamentos
que eu tive nada mais justo do que eu
trabalhar para isso
e foi então que eu fiz a pergunta e
agora será que aquilo acaba aqui
será que tem mais que será que eu posso
fazer então eu me tornei presidente da
organização que me levou
é eu tenho a honra hoje de liderar um
grupo de jovens que me ensina todos os
dias me desafia é com 21 anos eu tenho a
responsabilidade de pessoas que estão
pelo mundo todo e diversos voluntários
que vem pra cá porque seria muito pouco
dizia minha eu olhar todas as situações
e comovê ignorar o meu país
o bairro do meu lado ignorar todos os
problemas que a gente tem aqui e aí eu
comecei tá que o posso como a gente pode
aumentar isso e se eu pudesse mandar
pessoas para o mundo todo para terem
experiências parecidas com a minha
mas além de tudo eu pudesse trazer
pessoas de fora para entender a
realidade do brasil e trabalharem por
ele também
essa organização busca desenvolver
liderança jovem
hoje eu tenho a oportunidade de
trabalhar por isso porque eu acredito
que os jovens hoje são a chave para os
líderes melhores amanhã
então quando a gente fala de a nossa
política é triste empresários envolvidos
em escândalos de corrupção a gente
começará então se a gente tem líderes
que a gente não concorda qual nosso
trabalho para formar novos líderes eo
questionamento final é que eu tive até
durante enquanto estava montando essa
apresentação no mesmo esquema do vídeo
que a gente viu de em cima da hora
porque também para oxi no hfa fala tanto
liderança falei de problemas que vive do
outro lado do mundo 14 mil quilômetros
de distância
mas e os problemas que têm aqui a gente
fala tanto de problemas do brasil a
gente fala tanto de uma série de
questões socioeconômicas que nos
incomodam a gente fala de um acesso
restrito a gente fala de preconceito
onde homofobia e racismo mas qualquer
nossa responsabilidade com o nosso país
e qual como você se sentiria se você
fosse o líder que estivesse à frente do
brasil
qual que é a nossa responsabilidade está
tão preocupado em falar que está errado
que tá feio que a gente tem que mudar
mas você se comporta como líder que você
gostaria que estivesse à frente do
brasil
obrigado
[Aplausos]